okay everybody here we go Kanye West is
running for president of the United
States of America maybe I could tell you
I told you so I didn't tell you he was
gonna run for president but I did very
carefully
tell everybody to watch Kanye West back
in 2019 that many of the cultural shifts
will happen in his wake and in the wake
of people like him so we're going to
look at what's going on we're gonna look
at some of his pronouncements the frame
that he is proposing for his run in the
presidency and we will also see what the
end of clown world can look like what
happens when the fool starts to say
things which are the wise things that no
one dares to say anymore and this seems
to be the case in Kanye's pronouncements
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
so in July for 2020 Kanye West announced
officially that he was running to for
the United States presidency he has said
things like this before he has mentioned
that he would like to run for the
presidency but he had been pointing now
to 2024 but now this announcement came
on the 4th of July on this strange 4th
of July where people weren't allowed to
celebrate but we saw these mass
celebrations nonetheless we saw all
these people putting out fireworks from
their homes hundreds and hundreds of
people it was pretty astounding to see
it happened it actually looked like the
end of a movie when there is this one
clip where you see all these fireworks
going off and then you see you hear in
the background a reporter basically
going but but but but we told you you're
not allowed you're not allowed you can
get fine for doing this and it really
looks like the end of a movie where
everybody is defying you know the evil
tyrannical power or something like that
so it was fun but so Kanye announced
that he was going to run and there was
quite an amount of frenetic energy at
least in my mind I became very excited
just because last year I put out several
videos about Kanye West one of them
which was actually covered by Newsweek
looking at this notion of The Fool and
how in the time of chaos we need to
watch the fools and we need to look at
their pronouncements because when the
world is upside down the fool continues
to turn and will bring things right-side
up and so this is what we're seeing
right now and so Kanye West you know a
few years ago had been you know has some
mental issues he actually was put into a
hospital because of his problems you
know he he has said that he's bipolar
that he has these extremes and you can
see it in his pronouncements when you
listen to interviews with him he goes on
these kind of stream-of-consciousness
rants and he can talk and talk for hours
about all these different ideas he cuts
from one subject to the other but in
what he's saying this is when the
fascinating thing you can see
how he's slowly pointing towards things
which are actually the foundation of
civilization the foundation of order and
we see the same with his album the last
album we put out Jesus's King if you're
interested in that go see the video that
I put out about him this to Vito that I
will put links for in the description so
let's look at his bid for presidency he
started with a tweet in which he said we
must now realize the promise of America
by trusting God unifying our vision and
building our future I'm running for
president of the United States and so
the interesting thing to notice in his
tweet is just how concise the tweet is
and how powerful the tweet is you can
imagine him I don't know that he he put
that out you know really very
intuitively but in the tweet you can see
exactly the things that people need to
understand the very deep wisdom that I'm
talking about that no one dares to say
anymore he's saying things that no one
has the guts to talk about and so he
starts with the notion of trusting God
unifying our vision and building the
future now this is really the structure
of reality that is that in order to
build something you need to have a
unifying vision and the difficulty is
where do you put the unifying vision now
those who are wise have understood that
the higher you put this unifying vision
the better chance you have of actually
being able to build something that's
going to hold and of course the highest
thing that you can look to to unify your
vision is God and that is why you have
in the United States the last let's say
desire to hold unity within the United
States was done under the guides of God
we see it in the Pledge of Allegiance
one nation under God we see it also on
the currency in god we trust'
that is that we need to submit to the
highest highest principle in order for
us to be able to cohere together and so
one
God one nation we acknowledge the very
very highest in India and not we
acknowledge the thing which binds us
together in terms of the nation but the
nations are arbitrary unless they are
they are prone to conflict they are
prone to inner inner turmoil to Civil
War unless they are submitted to
something which is above them and that
is why all civilizations have always had
a religious ideal to which they hold and
of course the the transcendent God of
Christianity the transcendent God of the
West is you know the highest highest
possible thing that you can unify under
and so he he in his tweet he is actually
pointing to the structure of reality
he's showing us how reality works and
how if we want four things to hold
together how the order of the way things
have to be so you have God above you
have a unifying vision and then you can
build the future then you can acquire
the potentiality of the future and you
can unite it into your one vision okay
it's the same for any project we'll have
to have a unifying vision so that you
can build the future take the
potentiality that comes to you and
unites it to that the unknown that comes
to you and unites it into the one vision
so what's interesting again when I talk
about clown world when I talk about the
problem of the upside-down world is that
in this case him saying that him saying
tweeting this out publicly
looks like the craziest thing anybody
can say right now and you can see the
media class and the elite class just
laughing at someone who dares to say
something as insane as oh we need to
unify our vision by trusting God my
goodness
this is crazy but it is actually he's
actually pointing to the very structure
of reality what he's saying is the
wisest thing anybody can say but he sang
it in in a way that may
that looks crazy and this is where the
end becomes the beginning this is where
the the entertainer clown you know kind
of frantic character ends up actually
showing us the highest ideal brings us
back into order this is something I've
been talking about forever the notion of
this double inversion of how the the
fool will bring back order and here is a
clear example of this happening and
Kanye West put out an interview on
Forbes magazine and we're gonna go
through some of the elements of the
interview because in the interview he
does this over and over so in the
interview with Forbes magazine first of
all the interviewer gives you a sense of
this frantic interview that he's had
with Connie he says the interview lasted
for three hours and if you've ever
watched Kanye speak for a long time you
can see you can imagine what it was like
you can imagine him kind of talking and
talking and and going off and bring me
in ideas and there's a kind of there's a
kind of electric energy in the way that
Connie talks about things and there's
something which at first view looks like
a kind of convoluted or discontinuous
way of speaking but if you take a little
bit of time to see what he's saying he
he's actually saying things which are
very coherent another person I mentioned
who talks in similar manners is someone
like Alex Jones when you listen you when
you see how Jones speak he uses very
hyperbolic language talks about psychic
vampires and he talks about aliens and
and in demons and all of he uses all of
this kind of language but when you
actually look at what he's saying some
you can see that behind it there's an
inner coherence and he's actually
pointing to things which are which makes
sense not always but but often you can
see that he's actually pointed to
something which makes sense once you
analyze what he's actually saying and
you kind of look through the bluster and
the hyperbolic language and it's the
same thing with Connie here in this
interview and so when you look at what
the Forbes in the Forbes interview what
he says that the author gives us a kind
of summary at the beginning so we're
gonna read the summary and we're gonna
see what this is pointing to and how
things which look very very crazy not
but look very hyperbolic in the way that
they're presented are actually pointing
to something very high and are actually
pointing to a deep pattern and so he
starts and he says that Kanye West is
running for president 2020 under a new
banner the birthday party with guidance
from Elon Musk and an obscure vice
president candidate he's already chosen
the obscure vice president and Angel
candidate is like some pastor in the US
and he said that it's like anything I've
ever done in my life says West I'm doing
it to win and first the first thing you
notice is the birthday party now when
you hear that can you imagine a
political party called the birthday
party and it looks like something looks
like someone who's making fun of
politics and in a way I think that
there's an aspect of it which is true
but there's also an aspect which is
pointing to something more which is that
the notion of a birthday party is the
idea of celebrating your origin the idea
of celebrating the thing that makes you
you and I think that that's what he's
intuitively pointing to he's pointing to
the notion of his unifying vision but
he's also bringing the notion of a kind
of celebratory carnival aesthetic with
the notion of the origin he is closing
the gap he's ending the carnival he's
bringing the carnival into celebrating
something which is actually the origin
of our existence he wants to bring
everything under God and so he has
birthday party and those two things are
the end of clown world right the place
where the celebration were the party
where the carnival turns to now really
celebrate the origin so he says that
he's never voted in his life which is
hilarious
to think that someone who's never voted
is running for president he then said
that he's suspicious of the corona virus
vaccine and says that it's the mark of
the beast now this is something again
which hopefully I'll probably make a
video about this which when people start
to talk about the corona virus vaccine
this notion of the mark of the beast and
being chipped and everything it sounds
like extremely hyperbole
language and kind of crazy talk but when
you actually look at it and you look at
what it's referencing and what are the
fears behind it you'll see that the
fears are extremely reasonable and also
the system that people are using by
saying mark of the beast or the chip or
whatever that the system of control is
nonetheless there in our society and is
nonetheless always looming on our
periphery something which is always in
danger of encroaching onto our lives the
idea of being of being fully identified
by the state and fully followed by the
state is something which is not at all
conspiracy it's it's right there now
that the manner in which is it's going
to happen is up for debate but the the
idea that this is coming to us on the
horizon anybody who doubts that is the
one who's actually naive so he says that
planned parenthood has been placed in
sites inside cities by white
supremacists to do the devil's work
this of course is phrased in a way which
also sounds quite wild but is also not
completely false you know we we know
that there in the origins of Planned
Parenthood there are some very shady
things about eugenics that are that are
there and so he says it in a very
hyperbolic way about the devil's work
and all of this but nonetheless he's
saying things but nobody is allowed to
say publicly but which are also pointing
to some some underlying truths and then
he said that he envisions a White House
based on the secret country of what
Conda and black panther and you know the
you know that the reporter is putting
these things next to each other in order
to make all of this sound wild and crazy
but in the the movie black panther you
really do have a interesting culture a
culture which is very cohesive a culture
which is very aristocratic
a culture in which the the king is able
to unite different tribes together with
by respecting their different identities
as tribes and bring them together into
one nation and so there's something
about that which is not completely
which is not at all crazy and so he says
a lot of things which I won't go into
everything he says but I want to point
out to a few of the things that are
mentioned in this article I will of
course put the link to the article in
the description so that you can find it
yourselves on the coronavirus cure he
says we pray we pray for the freedom
it's all about God we need to stop doing
things that make God mad now once again
this is something which you know in a
secular society in a world that has in
the world of Enlightenment values if
someone says this publicly says that the
reason why we are struggling with this
with this problem is because we made God
mad and in that it's all about God that
people will say Oh bogus superstition Oh
silly silly thinking magical thinking
all of this but once again look at the
way that everybody is fighting about how
to deal with this disease and the reason
why people are fighting about how to
deal with this disease has nothing to do
with science it is an image of the
fractured society we have of our
incapacity to have unity our incapacity
to have a coherent discussion and a
transcendent value and that is the
reason for the conflict it is actually
not about medical it's a political
conflict and so when we say that it's
all about God and that we that it is by
not doing things that make God mad that
we could come out of this problem what
he's saying is absolutely true that if
we were able to have something which
unites us would you have something and
of course God is the ultimate thing
which unites us then we would be able to
to find a way to deal with this which
would be coherent and also we would also
be able to find the balance between the
extremes which is we can see that people
are giving in to these extremes of fear
and protection or now the extremes of
denying the very existence of the virus
and so if and and also people are
suspicious a lot of people say things
like the virus doesn't exist this is all
a conspiracy why are we saying that why
are people saying that they're saying
that because we have lost the coherence
of our society and people are doubting
their authorities people are doubting
those who are responsible for telling us
what is going on they think that they're
being lied to and the reason why they
think they're being lied to you is
because we are living through a
breakdown a social breakdown we're
living through at the end of a
civilizations end and so when he says
that it's all about praying and it's all
about God and it's all about doing not
doing the things that make God mad he is
absolutely right he's absolutely right
in a technical sense not in a
superstitious just religious sense he's
right that is because we do not have
this that all the rest is going on and
everything else is breaking down if we
could unify and be humble under the
divine the divine guidance then we would
be able to avoid we would trust our
leaders if they if we knew that they
were submitted to God and we would not
be doubting we would not be saying we
would not be even arguing over whether
or not this is real whether or not the
whether or not the instructions that are
being given to us by our authorities are
for our betterment you know all of this
would be avoided and so another
statement which is amazing that he makes
they asked him about his foreign policy
and the quote is I haven't developed it
yet
but then he says and which sounds like
of course that that you know the
unplanned fool who's there saying you're
gonna run for president but doesn't have
a platform there's of course in extreme
honesty about it he's not pretending but
he also says then he says I'm focused on
protecting America first with our great
military let's focus on ourselves first
this is of course this links to his
notion of wakanda and the note and the
idea of the wakandan state which is
akina's and which was mostly based on
preserving the coherence of its inner
elements that inner tribes rather than
trying to take over or to siphon thee
and get their interest from the outside
and so I mean can you imagine if someone
did this
like it would be it they mean the
America would maybe stop fighting war
after war after war I mean wouldn't that
be nice if that would happen if the
imperial the imperial tendrils of the
united states were less spread all over
the world to their own detriment
ultimately and then of course he says
I'm pro-life because I'm following the
word of the Bible you know once again it
is very difficult in in the world right
now in terms of media let's say the the
consensus the kind of social consensus
to say that you're pro-life and to say
it as explicitly and that not argue
about science this and this and that and
ethics and this and just say I'm I'm
following the word of the Bible and he's
right so the last thing I want to point
you in this article which is worth is
there are several things read the
article is definitely worth it because
you can see him go and and use extremely
hyperbolic language and and kind of wild
speech but then he talks about spirit
prayer in schools and he says we need to
reinstate in God's state in God's
country the fear and love of God in all
schools and organizations and you chill
the fear and love of everything else and
so that's it he's right first of all he
says it in a kind of freestyle rapping
which is amazing with some rhyme in
there but he's right in the sense that
it's not just about the idea of prayer
in schools or whatever but he
understands how reality works he
understands that if you do not have a
transcendent unity in the trends if you
don't have unity in the transcendent
then you will have a problem with the
unity and you'll have a problem with the
the fear of people fearing each other
and you'll have less love between other
things so he says so that was a plan by
the devil to have our kids committing
suicide at an all-time high by removing
God to have murders in Chicago at an
all-time high because the human beings
working for the devil remove God and
prayer from the schools that means more
draw
more murder more suicide and so of
course this is unacceptable you can't
say this no one is allowed to say this
in public discourse but here he is
saying it straight out and he's right
what he's saying is absolutely true he
is he is saying what I've been telling
you guys about just the way reality
works you know that why do people commit
suicide they commit suicide because they
they they are falling apart because they
do not have meaning they do not have
something a purpose which is uniting
them you know why do people take drugs
why do people commit murder you know all
of all of this is happening because of
the meaning crisis but the meaning
crisis is ultimately a spiritual crisis
it is a spiritual crisis of the West
which is leading to all the other
problems that the West has and all the
all the fragmentation that that is
happening and so read the article it is
definitely worth your time and also try
to understand this try to understand
what is happening that as you read the
article you will see some of the things
he says are extremely wild and were
really said in a manner that is that is
extreme but at the same time he is
saying very basic wisdom he's saying
things that are basically the way
reality works in a straight word
straight saying just saying it straight
out without any filter and that is
exactly the image of the end of clown
world it is exactly the image of the end
of the the entertainer in an upside-down
world finally pointing to basic wisdom
to basic truth in a way that looks still
crazy for most people and why does it
look crazy it looks crazy because the
world is crazy and so saying things like
put prayer back in school and and
abortion is evil and it's the work of
the devil all of that looks crazy it
sounds crazy because the world is crazy
and so all I can say is maybe vote for
Kanye you know I'm not American I'm
Canadian so I don't even have to decide
but think about it
and we'll see you very soon hope you
enjoyed this analysis of Kanye West run
for president
always remember that everything I'm
doing here is thanks to your support so
as usual please subscribe if you're not
subscribed share these videos because
obviously YouTube is not on our side and
also check out the new merchandise that
I have developed with on Cyclops which
is precisely on this point it is that
watch the fools image where we see the
fool pulling the King back up on top and
so thanks everybody for your attention
[Music]